give me back my brothers yeah what he
said you don't know what you're talking
about troll you're stealing broen's
talent because you have none of your own
you big oh you big phonies okay we need
to leave right
now in the history of
Cinema there's no other conert they'll
be referencing this for years he kept
saying it was like James Bond on
mushrooms what's up now
Rous you didn't think we were just going
to give you a boring Old Stage show did
you that's what we explicitly bought
tickets for act three the big one it's
so buckers so buckers I know it went
through a big change at one point I know
if you want to talk a little bit about
where we started we had this other idea
for act three but it didn't escalate to
something so finally after trying it a
few screenings maybe a year in I said
okay I got it like wait to talk to any
of you guys I'm like it's uh car chase
follow that luxury vehicle on it puppy a
musical car chase and a roller coaster
ride through this world that we haven't
even figured out yet we're taking this
show on the
[Applause]
road oh man I'm trying to get through
but they got no respect for the blinger
it was like all these elements and we
had no idea how we could do it or how we
could pull it
off oh this is too much I only have my
Learners permit yeah we were already
combining a lot of concepts for the
world yeah and then can you do a concert
on
Wheels it was a city in the sky that had
no floor right and um all of the
characters were teenagers in bumper cars
yeah and then we added the concert and a
car chase happening at the same time I'm
kind of freaking out a little bit so we
were like okay how do we get an audience
to surround the car that they're running
after so that it feels like the front
row of a concert yeah and so we ended up
creating these roller coaster roads that
had traffic on both sides so you can get
the hands up you know you see an ocean
of hands up at a concert really close to
the the villains who are performing that
song during the Chase and that became
like the thing that got us even more
excited it was so wild we didn't know
how we were going to do it and then on
top of that the world was made out of
completely new materials right like we
wanted the opposite of troll village
where troll Village is saw in fiber and
organic like plants and trees and Moss
this was going to have none of that it
was all about jewelry and hard facets
and gold and Glitz and Glam so how are
the little felt and trolls going to look
in this world oh no hold on your
cupcakes you've got your trolls that are
this big they're like an ant and then
you've got our world which is like your
house at home like those are that's the
difference in our scale here it was huge
it was multi-layered um um and we
started at the rage Dome where they were
supposed to have a concert all right
rages now is the moment we've all been
waiting for was it supposed to open up
I'm trying to remember wasn't that like
an idea we had so many which is all
could have been why didn't you do that
oh it was sorry everybody I didn't do
that we like we can't do that thata
that's too
crazy yeah a stadium that opens up it's
impossible and they like okay let's do
something totally bigger than that so
then we just did the Chase and we jumped
off of that building hold her steady
tiny and ended up having this road that
circled around it and then kept going
with this spiral oh my gosh the spiral
was so hard it took our modeler and our
our layout Department weeks to get that
to look right with the camera so that
what we seeing now in the film is is
this thing that's like literally
spiraling you feel like you're on that
roller coaster uh guys what this end of
the road
mean if the mini golf was our first
challenge with scale this was like the
Behemoth of scale so we had to come up
with lots of tricks to be able to make
the city render to make the characters
look proper I don't think I can do it
again everyone put your hands up for
that tantalizing tuome velvet and
[Music]
veneer one of the things I always find
fascinating is that delin veneer are
villains most people that I know that
have been watching the film they cannot
tell with we pulled the strick off but
we rigged and set up one character ban
face and that is all of them like Melvin
veneer the same body face all the city
is all made up of one character but we
changed the hair the clothing the colors
it's like I don't even know who you are
yeah you do we really focused on
creating Variety in Silhouettes so all
these characters that are in the crowd
they're wearing onesies like pajama
onesies cuz all the teenagers do that
and the city's the city's only populated
by teenagers so we would give them
hoodies and then on top of that give the
hoodie like different types of ears the
ones these are really vibrant
contemporary color palettes some of them
have text some of them have print and
then with the hair since the characters
are made out of like vinyl they don't
actually have hair they look like clay
tubes like when you're a kid and you're
playing with plasticine and you sort of
make the pasta and so the hair had to be
almost we were really building like a
toy like how would you print it veneer
what's with your vibe in your face why
do you arresting Moody Vibe face no I
know we deserve to be famous just cuz we
want to but honestly that Dude Looks
rough that was important it was
important for the style the movie when
we were drawing the boards it was like
are these humans were they no there's no
humans in troll Universe at least not
yet I always thought that just having
that one model that one rig like that we
would just dress up in different ways
was sort of the idea of that world that
it was all very kind of superficial
right and it's like everyone's kind of
the same underneath you know but they're
all trying to be unique like teenagers
do you know so yeah that quest for fame
now come on we're about to go from stars
to Mega stars but where we landed with
totally unique characters you know with
a lot of help from Craig kelman yeah
Craig and the 1930s fer
Brothers yeah it it led to such a fun
call back to that style of Animation too
I love what you guys did with the way
those villains move they're
communicating these same ideas but in
such an inventive way like the way they
would cross their legs or twist their
arms hip hip twist flip our dances
sucked of course yeah looking at some of
that inspiration from from back in the
day from old rubber hose animation I
think was was great V's always been my
inspiration my biggest inspiration hm
I'd have to go with also me and they
remember talking Walt with you and and
with Tim about this idea of I think
there was kind of like a mandate of just
not natural could we you know have them
move around and maybe not see such sharp
delineations in terms of like bones like
maybe they don't have bones per se that
really helped it helped tell our story
there were like toys like that's at the
root of this thing Crim what are you
doing why are you always hovering uh I'm
standing well be a good little assistant
and go stand in the corner oh yes do we
want to talk a little bit about CRI vet
and veneer assistant that's one of my
favorite characters and she she's a very
unique uh species or type of character
and it's kind of curious how that came
up out yeah that she's amazing this
character came in where she was at first
kind of a ball of hair to kind of anchor
you into the familiarity of the troll
Universe oh it looks like you need a hug
so Tim Heights Drew this little kind of
crimped hair hair thing like okay that
looks like a troll movie that'll help
and eventually she became paper we took
that idea of the little character and
circled around it with different
materials and different functions and
like what what makes sense for an
assistant to be made out of and then
eventually we got this gift from the
studio I think Val Valentine's gift and
the packing paper right the packing
paper was a shredded paper it was it was
packing paper crimped like folded red
packing paper and I can't remember if it
was Craig or Gina that was like What if
she's made out of that paper T crimp
honey that's not an idea those are
shoulder pads so I went home and made
crimp out of the paper and showed it to
Craig and Craig's like oh yeah and he
took that and just added these cool
glasses and a little face and the little
hands and turned out it was perfect she
was an assistant like an office
assistant made out of office supplies
it's our tribute to the assistant yeah
it's barely done cuz they they help us
all go you know great job cringe you're
smarter than I thought now I don't trust
you that's maybe not a rational response
I don't um please don't put me in the CL
then you know that just shows you an
idea where it comes from it could come
from anywhere even from like the first
pitch that Tim did it was like oh that
character is in the movie like you knew
it like you're like oh she's going to be
here for a while wow this is liberating
when we come together there is nothing
that we can't do I'm still blown away
when I watch the film and see all those
elements come together I mean it starts
as just some silly words in a room and
then some silly drawings well that's the
crazy part it's a blank slate we're like
okay everyone and everyone keeps
building on it right like you start with
the words you guys go to the boards and
really just how you can stretch that
down and art and rough layout start
really kind of building out a city
that's fascinating we don't have to be
perfect to be in harmony we just have to
be as we are together then it comes down
to you guys and it's like how we going
to I think that's always the thing right
is that when you when you hear these
pitches like it's it's always for me
it's always like two emotions it's it's
always that like awesome that's so great
then I'm like oh my God I have no idea
you're smiling and crying at the same
time it kind of looks like it's hurting
your face it does hurt my face I know
it's going to get done you know what I
mean I just have no idea how we're you
know going to get there people watch the
film now and they just come to me they
go how I'm like I don't know it just
takes lots of hard work and loads of
natural Talent one of the things that I
love the most about the trolls world or
that that Drew me to it from the very
beginning was just this joy and
celebration of music and love and
friendship get up here we're in the band
this is my dream life I can't imagine
people not you know dancing and moving
around you know and having such a great
time as they like leave you know the
theater like it just feels like it ends
it on such a joyful you know fun note
and I feel like I don't for me that's
what the trolls films you know are all
about and that's it does people are
dancing I I say a lot what do you get
out of a trolls movie if you go see one
I said well I hope you feel better
coming out before you came in yeah yeah
so how you feeling happy grateful and it
feels like it has that effect it really
does yeah oh yeah I totally see it
best
[Music]
ever